how did vampires and werewolves stay
hidden for 600 years what is their
bullet budget why is it so dark what's
up with the wings is that cat suit even
comfortable these are some of the many
questions that need to be examined from
the underworld movies
the plot of 2012's underworld awakening
hinges on humans discovering the
existence of vampires and lichens yet
the two supernatural species existed for
centuries prior to humanity's
realization while the first film
indicates that vampires and lykans have
attempted to operate in the shadows it
seems impossible that their conflict had
gone on notice for so long in the second
film underworld evolution alexander
corvinus the first immortal indicates he
spent his long life covering up the
indiscretions of the two species his
twin sons originated but it's hard to
believe he never slipped up over the
course of the centuries-long bloodshed
between vampires and lichens furthermore
in modern times vampires and lykan's use
of loud guns without silencers would
make them especially likely to attract
attention at a minimum people should
have noticed during the first underworld
as the two groups have an intense gun
battle in a subway catching multiple
humans in the crossfire
in the mythology of underworld kate
beckinsale celine and scott speedman's
michael are supposed to be supernatural
star cross lovers as michael goes from
human to lycan to lycan vampire hybrid
throughout the first film he and celine
are also supposed to be falling for each
other while the plot of the film makes
this clear beckensel and speedmen as
actors do not theirs is supposed to be
an earth-shattering love instead their
romance is about as sexy as a damn towel
and have you
moved on
have you even in the second film as
celine and michael finally consummate
their relationship the audience gets a
scene that shows a lot of skin yet never
bears much of anything unfortunately
beckinsale generates more heat by
herself by talking about her feelings
for michael or interacting with his
corpse when she thinks he's dead late in
the second movie
underworld rise of the likens is a
prequel that explains the centuries old
origins of the war between lycans and
vampires focusing on lycan lucien and
his forbidden relationship with vampire
sonia which tragically results in the
latter being killed by her father and
vampire leader victor when he discovers
that she's pregnant with a lycan child
yet even if you haven't seen the third
film in the series this story may sound
familiar that's because lucian relates
it in the first film and if that weren't
enough michael experiences it in a
series of brief flashbacks so while rise
of the likens expands on the story it's
still a rehash of a storyline that was
summed up in just a few minutes in the
first underworld
alexander corvinus passed the trait of
eternal life on to his twin sons marcus
and william who became the first vampire
and werewolf respectively while william
was unable to assume his human form ever
again the movie indicates marcus became
a vampire just like the others presented
in the franchise that is until we meet
him in underworld evolution and learn
that he has giant bat wings the apparent
result of being awoken from a lengthy
sleep by the blood of a slain likened
scientist marcus spends a majority of
the film flying around and using his
wings as weapons but it's unclear why he
has them early in the story celine tells
michael he's the first vampire-like and
hybrid and therefore there are no limits
to what he might be capable of the
question is why lichen blood would cause
marcus to sprout wings instead of
adopting more lichen-like traits in the
end it seems marcus was given his winged
advantage because he's the first vampire
but the movie never offers any real
explanation
in most vampire properties the species
is particularly vulnerable to wooden
stakes through the heart and sunlight
the underworld franchise adheres to only
half of that lore as the only thing that
will definitely take out this
franchise's vampires is sunlight in fact
vampire's vulnerability is so extreme
that their likened enemies have learned
to make uv bullets so they can destroy
vampires even when the sun is down yet
while many vampires die from exposure to
uv light throughout the series there are
also many more deaths that aren't
dependent on the sun for example victor
dies when celine lobs off half of his
head with a sword another elder amelia
dies when she is drained of blood
although there's a certain logic to
these deaths they're still somewhat
surprising more surprising still are the
deaths of two vampires in the series
second entry who selene takes out by
simply punching them and throwing them
against the wall given the strength and
durability the species is supposed to
possess it's hard to believe such a
thing would end the life of even the
weakest vampire
with the exception of underworld
awakening the series takes place in an
unnamed city in eastern europe from the
looks of the language seen on some of
the signs that city is likely in hungary
yet almost every character speaks with
an english or american accent
[Music]
how you doing most puzzling of all
however is the fact that when we first
meet michael in underworld he's clearly
american yet he's an intern at a local
hospital and the only co-worker he talks
to is a fellow american but if michael
and his co-worker want to be licensed
doctors in the united states they
wouldn't do their internships in eastern
europe perhaps the films were supposed
to feel like they could take place
anywhere but there's just enough
evidence for them being set in a
specific real world location to make the
character's accents extremely confusing
from the opening scene of the first
underworld one thing is abundantly clear
when vampire death dealers find their
likened targets their first response is
to unleash a barrage of bullets to take
them down this would be expensive enough
if they used regular bullets but because
lycans are vulnerable to silver they
mostly employ specially made silver
bullets which would be even more costly
this means the vampire's budget for
their centuries-long war with the
lichens must be massive given the
expense and the need to keep the war a
secret from humans it's surprising the
vampires on the front lines of the
battle weren't trained to conserve
bullets by being more strategic about
where and when they fire but instead
their philosophy seems to be shoot first
and as much as possible
underworld features multiple immortal
fathers and their supernatural children
but there are two prominent examples who
present a sharp contrast on one hand
there's the original immortal alexander
corvinus whose sons became the first
vampire in werewolf after alexander
reveals he spent his lengthy existence
covering up the havoc his children have
wreaked across the centuries he's asked
why he didn't just kill his sons but he
acts like it would be impossible for him
or any other father to do such a thing
despite this his son marcus demonstrates
he doesn't feel the same loyalty to his
father given that a short time later he
kills alexander while remarking on his
cold heart on the other hand there's
victor and his daughter sonia while
victor initially seems to want to secure
a high place in vampire society for
sonia he condemns her to death when he
learns that she's having an affair with
the lycan lucian and is pregnant with
his child yet sonia supposed crime is
far less horrific than those of marcus
and william this is easy to overlook
while watching the films but examining
the two story lines side by side
demonstrates the warp priorities of the
series of mortals
since its very first outing the
underworld franchise has employed a
highly stylized blue filtered look
however there's one drawback to this
choice it makes it seem like the story
takes place entirely at night on the
first underworld film this was an
advantage since it just so happens that
none of the action was set during the
day however in subsequent films
vampire's allergy to the sun becomes an
important plot point yet in each
instance the films have to strain to
ensure the audience understands what's
going on since it's challenging to
interpret based on what we're seeing
which is still very dark nowhere is this
more obvious than in the third film rise
of the likens which goes to great
lengths to ensure viewers understand the
sun is rising because of the visual
palate chosen in the first underworld
and maintained through the others it is
often impossible for audiences to
distinguish between day and night
there are multiple clues to how vampire
society works that we can glean during
the series from the way the creatures
conduct themselves first the vampires
live together in one location as a coven
in underworld it's clear there are at
least two covens although the
information presented in later films
confirms there are actually more between
the authoritarian-like leadership and
insistence that everyone live together
in order to ensure they can be
controlled and ordered around it seems
vampire society hasn't changed in
centuries even as the world has moved on
at one point celine comments that
vampires don't change yet when it comes
to clothes and fighting her leather
outfit and big guns indicate that in
some ways vampires have evolved so why
hasn't vampires style of living and
leadership changed at least the teeniest
bit
victor's lie about who truly killed
celine's family is only one of many
deceptions and omissions of truth that
drive the plots of the underworld films
help him
of course not
are you lying to me
in fact there are so many characters
keeping secrets often for centuries that
it becomes easy to forget just how much
the series hinges on various falsehoods
like craven's claim he killed lucian and
his and lucian's subsequent alliance or
thomas never telling his son david that
his mother is the vampire elder amelia
so while supernatural creatures
certainly have a lot to hide from the
human population in underworld the
vampires and lycans find plenty of
reasons to hide things from one another
as well often for selfish reasons that
typically come back to haunt them
the leather catsuit kate beckinsale
wears in the underworld films has become
iconic the irony is that celine's chosen
fighting uniform is completely
impractical for any kind of actual
fighting while the leather will
certainly prevent her from getting hurt
too badly if she takes a tumble that
doesn't seem like it would be a huge
concern after all her vampire healing
should be enough to ward off any issues
if she falls on the other hand the
leather in her suit will only constrict
her movements overheat her and make so
much noise that it would be very easy to
hear her sneaking up behind you of
course celine is a vampire so it's
possible she doesn't feel extreme
temperatures and she's strong enough to
overcome any limitations of the
catsuit's leather but celine is also a
professional death dealer so it seems
likely she would want to choose clothing
that would best support her work
in the underworld franchise there are at
least three separate occasions where a
female vampire becomes pregnant first
after having an affair with lucian sonja
becomes pregnant then in the fourth film
celine is awoken after being held for 12
years in a government facility by the
daughter she didn't know she was
pregnant with when she was captured
finally in the fifth film it's revealed
that david's mother was actually the
vampire elder amelia when sonja revealed
her pregnancy she claimed it was a
miracle but given how often it comes up
in the franchise it seems vampire
pregnancy is in fact possible although
like so many other things in these
movies the filmmakers seem to be loafed
to provide additional information check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite vampire franchises are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you